you all feel that rejection kills dreams
we all feel that failure kills dreams we
all feel that people kill dreams but
actually there's four words that we say
in our heads to ourselves that genuinely
have destroyed more dreams than all of
those things put together those four
words are what will people say
what will people say how many times have
you stopped yourself from doing
something because you're scared of how
people will react how many times out of
the fear of someone else's opinion or
criticism have you stopped yourself from
doing what you believe in how many times
has someone's perception or perspective
stopped you from living your potential
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you you've got michael jordan
level genius at something so today let's
live your best believe life and get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only jay shetty
enjoy
no matter what you choose to do there
will always be people who find a fault
with it there will always be people who
criticize complain who try to bring you
down and tell you that what you're doing
isn't right it's crazy that we give up
what we most want in life just based on
people's opinions and the crazy thing is
if we're living for other people's
opinions we'll never be right there'll
always be someone with something that
they won't agree with and this is why
it's so important that we work with our
own conviction we work on what matters
to us it was aristotle who told us that
there were only three ways to avoid
criticism do nothing say nothing be
nothing and i'm sure none of us want
that of our future so don't let anyone's
opinion stop you don't let anyone's
criticism hold you back keep following
your passions invest in what you believe
in and remember don't let people's
compliments get to your head and don't
let their criticism get to your heart
real empathy
is connecting to someone in their
emotional language
not yours
right that's real empathy that's real
connection that's real compassion is
that you're able to communicate with
someone and express your thoughts
in their emotional language not yours
and this is something we struggle with
because when we're feeling
tired exhausted stressed overworked we
communicate more in our language because
we want to be heard
not realizing that when we fight for
being heard
we actually alienate the other person
they're just disconnected because we're
speaking a foreign language that's
literally what it sounds like
if this group is talking to this group
and they're only talking about goals and
schedules and plans
this group is going to say but what
about the people
what about people are exhausted people
are tired what about how they feel
that doesn't mean they don't agree with
you
they just want you to take into account
people
it's not that they don't agree with your
plans and goals and schedules and any of
that
and you may sit there and go well they
don't understand they just don't get it
like we need to hit these targets they
don't understand
but you're both on the same team
[Music]
you both need each other both mindsets
are important so then the question
becomes
how
do we care about people in the pursuit
of our goal and that's where all the
focus goes the focus now isn't well
we're right because we're going to hit
targets and that's what pays for
everything or no we're right because we
care about people and obviously people
are everything it becomes well how do we
hit our targets and care for people how
do we do that if we both start having
that conversation you get some
incredible synergy so much of our life
and society and our being today is
divided we have
work and life
we have family and friends we have
personal and professional
and so many of our challenges in life
come from the fact that we think we have
to be in two places at once
that we have two sets of
responsibilities
and when we talk about our well-being
we often think that's what we do after
work
that's what we deal with when we get
home that's what we try and do on the
weekend
and then when we're at work we're
wondering whether our well-being is in
the right place
i've sat down and interviewed some
incredible individuals uh jocko willink
being one of them
and when i've sat down with these navy
seals i've talked to them so much about
the power of breath
the power of presence the power of
stillness we often think that force
is the most powerful thing in the world
and sometimes when you speak to the
strongest people in the world they'll
say it's not force it's stillness
right stillness is the most powerful
thing in the world stillness creates
more force
than force itself
because that stillness creates clarity
it creates focus
so think about how you can find again
just two three minutes for that all of
these habits that i'm sharing today
should take you no longer than five
minutes each
and then finally e t i m e e is for
exercise moving sweating uh one of my
favorite things is to see families
compete over ten thousand steps
you'll be shocked at how much
your partner is competitive when you all
put on a fitbit or a wearable or
whatever it may be
and see who gets the 10 000 steps first
the idea of moving
is so powerful for our mind and our
psychology
so those are four habits exercise
probably a bit longer than five minutes
but the rest of them if we could add
thankfulness
inspiration
meditation and exercise to our daily
weekly habits
you'll find that your personal
well-being
your personal connection with yourself
will elevate to levels that you never
could have imagined
the simple habits have a giant impact
these simple daily investments have
giant rewards
and they take very little time
they take very very little time and it's
also a beautiful thing to bring to the
table to practice with your children to
practice with your partner it's
something that
can be nicely brought into a family
activity
that makes it easier for each and every
individual
so that's the first thing the first
thing is you
if your foundations are set
if you're feeling rooted and grounded
everything else is possible from that
place people who are happy passionate
and successful are everywhere right
can't we just turn to them to see what
they did to get there
not quite ah come on
a few years ago gallup conducted an
international poll that included
questions about workplace happiness and
engagement how many people said they
felt engaged at work was it a 65
b 35
or c 15
if you guessed a you're way off the
answer is c
only 15 percent of people worldwide said
they felt engaged at work that means
that 85 of people around the world don't
find meaning and purpose in what they do
i need a different child
considering that according to writer
gemma curtis we spend 13 years and two
months of our lives at work that's a lot
of time being upset but when we look
around we see a different story right
social media posts show people pursuing
their dreams and living their best lives
and news and interviews showcase
entrepreneurs stumbling on that great
idea creating a company and selling it
all before age 25 yet as we just saw the
statistics don't bear this out in japan
a whopping 94 of survey respondents said
that they're not engaged at work it's a
bit better in the us but not much only
30 percent of workers say they're
happier with their work this is
colliding with what gallup says is an
increased focus on the value of work
among millennials they want a job and a
career that's dream worthy keep dreaming
it's worth a shot so in a world that's
so unhappy at work how do you make that
dream come true there's a single
powerful secret i'm going to share that
will help you sort it all out there's a
zen story about two monks standing in
the garden of the monastery watching
some prayer flags waving in the distance
one monk comments the wind is moving the
other monk shakes his head
no he says it's the flags that are
moving a senior monk walks by and the
two monks ask his opinion he said you
are both wrong it is your mind that is
moving that's the powerful secret that
in life it's actually less about what
you experience and more about how you
experience it that's important the truth
is actually less about what job you have
and more about how you do it that shapes
the quality of your life that actually
makes a lot of sense katrina lake didn't
know what to do after college so she
decided to work at a consulting firm it
was there that she became curious about
what would happen if you married
technology with clothing retail her
initial idea flopped but she kept
exploring going on to work for a venture
capital firm then on to business school
finally lake had her big idea she would
marry personal shopping with online
clothes buying she started shopping for
her friends and keeping meticulous data
about what they liked and didn't and why
business plan and spreadsheets in hand
she began to search for funding and was
turned down by more than 50 different
venture capitalists that didn't stop her
though periodically she would get just
enough money to keep going and building
her idea in 2017 lake became the
youngest woman in history to take a
company public and in 2020 stitch fix
was valued at 3.37 billion dollars lake
did an interview with the podcast
skimmed from the couch and was asked the
worst piece of advice she'd ever gotten
what was it follow your dreams lake says
the notion that your job should be your
dream job is misleading so many parts of
this job have not been a dream she said
whether it was struggling to raise money
cramming to get stitch fix boxes out the
door on time or being the one who had to
go out and buy a new printer when theirs
broke down here's the thing you can be a
stock broker who makes millions of
dollars but is miserable or you can be a
grocery clerk who changes others life
simply with your kindness and caring the
difference lies in how you approach life
and that difference comes from your
motivation i was 15 i really needed the
job i'll even tell you what it was i'll
confess i was applying to a local
supermarket and i wrote down that i
really really really wanted to work
there
that was my life there you go and i've
got nothing against supermarkets they're
awesome i actually really enjoyed the
experience afterwards and i'm glad i did
it how many of you have ever lied on a
resume or a cv tell me right now in the
comments and don't lie now i'm guessing
most of you wrote down no well that
means that 57 of you are lying because
that's how many of us embellish our
skill set on our resumes
55 of us lie about our responsibilities
it's when all you did was get starbucks
and coffee and you say that you were the
team performance manager or maybe all
you did was filing and copying and you
said you were the big project manager on
the job i do everything around here okay
42 of people lie about the dates they
worked it's when you work somewhere for
three days but you wrote three months
easy mistake oops 26 of people even lie
about the company they work for i work
for the cia they interviewed 2 000 hr
professionals and asked them what were
the most memorable resume likes i'm
gonna tell you them right now let's see
if you can see yourself in some of them
applicants claim to be the assistant to
the prime minister of a country that
doesn't have a prime minister applicant
claimed to have an olympic gold medal
applicant claim to have 25 years of
experience at age 32
minus 25
yeah seven you started working when you
were seven applicant applied for the
same position twice with different work
histories now i don't know who's gonna
fall for that but it's a pretty creative
idea i'd give them the job just based on
that so i started digging a bit deeper i
was looking at all these statistics and
wondering and asking myself why do we
like why is it that over half of the
people in the world lie on their resumes
to get these jobs to get these positions
we need the money that's true we need to
work that's true but there was something
at the root cause of it and i want to
talk to you about today one of the
biggest reasons is because there are so
many job specifications and requirements
out there now that are stopping us from
feeling confident but the root cause is
self-awareness when we were young we had
hobbies we had passions we had skills
that we could articulate that we could
share with people but as we've grown
older we've forgotten about them we
struggle to express our passion for
absolutely anything the more self-aware
we become the more confident we become
about the skills that we have we're so
busy trying to convince people that we
have skills that we don't even care
about that we forget the ones that we
really already have see the truth is
that everyone has potential and talent
but we've been made to believe that we
need to have a certain checklist to give
us a certain status when reality is a
lot of the people who are doing what
they love would never get a job and a
place out there we've been made to
believe that there are certain skills
and qualifications that define us but
i'm gonna ask you to answer this
question first what do you love and what
are you good at figure that out what do
you love and what are you good at and
invest in that see people say follow
your passions i say you can follow them
but make sure you work on them make sure
you invest in them make sure you improve
on them because as you get better as you
grow in what you love and what you're
good at that's going to become the most
powerful asset you have so next time you
think you're lying on a resume to get a
job think about whether that's a job you
really want the truth is that the world
we live in
will
always be
uncertain
unpredictable
and
potentially include chaos
and the challenge is
that
in that time
it's very hard to find
peace or find calm
or find
joy
and it's at those time
when we can use what we have
wherever in the world we are
to try to positively create peace
to try to serve others to try to
[Laughter]
be there for others
that is the only way that we can
experience peace by being
peace by creating peace by sharing peace
by sharing love
and
in terms of what we're looking for
when you're going through something
difficult you can't find happiness and
you often can't find peace immediately
but you can always find meaning and
service
and this is how we were trained to think
as monks that in times of uncertainty
don't look for certainty because you
won't find it look for service look for
where you can help
how you can help because when you start
making a change even in the smallest of
ways when you start supporting others
and helping others even in the tiniest
of ways
you start to see that there's hope
there's possibility there's opportunity
so start wherever you are i was around
nine years old and i was visiting india
with my family we were stuck in traffic
and we were driving through a slum area
it was the first time i'd seen homes
built out of cardboard scrap metal and
bricks all at the same time growing up
in london i'd never ever seen anything
like it before apart from on tv or in
the movies i saw some children on the
streets probably around the same age as
me but very different some of them
didn't have clothes they looked
undernourished and they probably didn't
have access to much water could tell by
the dryness on their lips and their skin
i noticed this one young girl who had a
head inside a trash can it looked like
she was scrambling for something when
she finally came out and looked at me
she smiled not knowing what to do i
smiled back she was obviously trying to
look for food and i could see her
scrambling and trying to reach in as far
as she could only then did i realize
that she only had arms she didn't even
have hands as she looked at me i could
tell she was hungry but by the time i
was just about to do something our car
took off and i could only see her now
and feel her disappointment that i
wasn't able to help at the time i didn't
have any food or money and before i
could ask my parents or the driver to
stop we were too far along on the
highway but i couldn't stop thinking
about her when we got back to the hotel
i got out of the car and it was lunch
time and even though i was really hungry
i couldn't eat because i couldn't get
over the fact that i couldn't have done
anything for that young girl that i just
saw even though i went to the buffet
with my parents it felt as if only me
and her had looked at each other in that
whole exchange and the whole city had
stopped i could remember exactly how she
looked as i was looking at the food when
we were there at the buffet i overheard
a couple arguing with the hotel stuff
listening into their conversation i
found out that the couple were really
upset at the hotel staff because of the
number of choices available in the
buffet i looked around there were so
many options they were complaining about
there not being enough choice but all i
could see
was choice there were at least 30 items
just as starters available to everyone
there but it wasn't enough for them now
i get that everyone has their own
standards has their own expectations in
life and we're allowed to have them and
i know that everyone is fighting their
own battle but that little girl she
didn't even have hands she was scraping
with whatever was left over arms but
many years on from that event now i've
learned a lot one of the things is that
i can sit here and be angry at that
couple who was complaining or i could
actually do something about it it
reminded me of a quote by gandhi he said
that i was sad because i didn't have any
shoes and then i saw a man with no feet
for me this event left a lasting
impression in my heart and two messages
that i want to share with you today the
first one is to remain grateful for
absolutely anything we have robin
roberts said it perfectly she said that
if we threw all our problems into our
pile we would rush to grab our own back
and when we start with gratitude and see
everything as fortune and grace we're
able to receive much more deeply and
number two let's help those who need it
let's not be mad that the world isn't
helping them let's see what we can do
compassion is key and empathy is
essential and that's one of the reasons
that i focus so much of my life in
trying to help those in need and it may
mean that you're in a space in your life
where you feel you can't currently help
anyone right now but i guarantee you
that there's just one person out on the
street today that you could impact that
you could change their experience at
least for a moment remember what gandhi
said i was sad because i didn't have any
shoes and then i saw a man with no feet
it puts everything into perspective i
think that people who found their
purpose
are better partners
better parents better professionals
better people
and so if everyone in the world was
deeply aligned and connected to their
purpose
the world would be a beautiful place and
i think any pain we see in the world
comes from a disconnect
with
purpose there's a beautiful
thought from russell barkley
where he said that the people who need
the most love
often ask for it in the most unloving
ways so we confuse love
[Music]
with
power
we confuse love
with control we confuse love with
validation and being liked
and to me love comes from living our
purpose self love
and true love with other people we all
have what's called the monk mind and the
monkey mind and as monks we were trained
to look at the parts of our minds that
we
make mistakes that fail that do things
wrong is the monkey mind and immediately
when you think of your mind like a
monkey you just end up laughing you're
just like that's just the silliest thing
and so now when you start seeing
yourself do things that are out of
character or out of alignment or things
that you don't feel proud of instead of
judging yourself and criticizing
yourself you're approaching it going
well that's just a monkey mind let me
understand that is separate of me that
is not me that is a habit that i've
taken on that is a group of people that
i've spent too much time with it's an
idea that i've absorbed if you can look
at these things as separate to who you
are
you can now actually tackle them versus
when you think you are them it just
leads to guilt judgment self-criticism
and self-sabotage which i'm sure a lot
of us are privy to that we go through
this period where we're like i can't
believe i did that i shouldn't have said
that i wish i just wish i didn't say
that in that moment and that doesn't
change your behavior it doesn't switch
how you feel it just creates more regret
but when you go wait a minute that's
just a monkey mind i've got that
condition i've associated with that type
of environment and energy let me
approach it as something that is
separate of me creating that distance
and space from our challenges lets us
actually start solving them it's one of
the biggest and most common things that
wears us out and weighs us down every
single day starting from the time we
wake up negativity doesn't it often feel
like everywhere you look most of the
headlines and social media posts even
messages from your friends and family
are negative why does it seem like no
matter where we turn negativity is just
coming at us from every direction i'm
not about that negativity when it comes
to negativity research tells us some
interesting things about human behavior
scientists from mcgill university set up
a study that participants were told was
about observing their eye tracking
patterns while they read news from a
webpage really the scientists just
wanted to see which articles the
participants picked and overwhelmingly
it was negative articles but why another
study reported in adweek showed that on
average negative headlines outperform
positive headlines by 63
and data from pew reset says that
two-thirds of americans say they feel
worn out by the sheer amount of news
that's out there just the quantity is
tiring and negative it's way too much
it's just too
much researchers also estimate that up
to 80 of our thoughts every day are
negative so i'm going to give you three
ways to lighten your negativity load so
you can start feeling more energized and
positively engaged scientists have
concluded that our over consumption of
negativity is due at least in part to
something called negativity bias we're
wired to detect threats so we give more
of our attention to things that are
negative so let's say you're out on a
hike in a gorgeous location there might
be 99 beautiful things to take in about
your surroundings the birds the trees
the cascading waterfall but the second
you hear a little rustle in the bushes
all of your attention will go to that
one sound because your brain is worried
it can be a threat did you hear that
there's also research that sheds some
light on what encourages negativity in
our social circles according to
neuroscientists certain receptors for
dopamine the reward chemical actually
become unavailable when we don't give a
socially desirable response to others if
your friends say let's go to the abc
grill for lunch you're more likely to
get that feel-good dopamine hit if you
say sounds great even if that's not what
you want to eat our brains want us to
fit in if you've ever participated in
gossip or other negative behavior and
then wondered why you did that this
helps to explain it well i feel better
about myself the negativity odds may
feel like they're stacked against us but
we really can decrease the negativity in
our lives and we do it through small
simple choices made consistently going
along with your friends even though you
disagree is like someone offering you a
sugary candy bar it's hard to resist and
tastes great in the moment but later you
feel the weight of that choice when
you're burned out tired potentially
depressed i made a mistake that food
analogy can be helpful when looking at
the negativity in our lives like junk
food junk thoughts and junk behavior are
weighing us down if i'm giving myself a
steady diet of refined sugar and
processed food if that's what i'm
ingesting i'm going to be tired and
cranky i'm awake i'm awake but if i eat
lots of fresh produce if i'm consuming
things that are more positive i'm going
to feel energized i'll feel more
motivated my mood will be better and my
thoughts will be clearer and that makes
it easier to make healthy decisions it's
self-perpetuating have you ever found it
when you're tired you eat worse when you
eat worse you're more tired if our daily
diet is made up of judgment and anger
we're going to feel terrible we won't be
as creative and we won't feel inspired
studies even show we won't be as
physically healthy because people who
are mostly negative get sick more often
it all starts in childhood we want to be
loved and accepted that's completely
normal but because of this need for love
and acceptance from just a few years of
age we begin to live according to what
others want for and from us we form
ideas about who and how we should be
based on what parts of us our behavior
and personality are welcome and praised
and which are not i like that about him
we also learn by imitating what we see
others doing as we grow older we shape
our likes and dislikes according to the
people we surround ourselves with for
example according to data from adweek
among 18 to 34 year olds 68 said that
their peers social media posts were at
least somewhat likely to influence them
to make a purchase i i got one for
myself see soon these attitudes and
behaviors we're imitating become
indistinguishable to us from who we
really are
in a pair of studies researchers
reviewed data from three different
seasons of the premier league football
play and concluded that referees
systematically favored home teams by
shortening close games where the home
team is ahead and lengthening close
games when the home team is behind the
reason
pressure from the home crowd so when it
comes to making decisions we change our
own picture of reality to avoid the
discomfort that comes when we go against
what others think and that's just
strangers imagine the influence of our
friends our families and co-workers and
the effect they have on us yeah but i'm
your brother we're family what finally
does make us question our thoughts and
behavior is often that we hit a wall
maybe we wake up one day and realize
we're dreading going to work maybe we're
sitting with a group of friends and
suddenly we think what am i doing here i
don't fit in with these people and then
we end up asking even more powerful
questions like what do i want to do with
my life and who am i really as
billionaire investor warren buffett once
said chains of habit are too light to be
felt until they are too heavy to be
broken and maybe that's how you feel
like you're being weighed down by this
version of you that you've been
pretending to be or had to be because of
life imagine your life was an empty jar
if you're filling that job with ideas
and beliefs that are not yours you're
living a life that isn't yours the first
type of filler we put in our lives that
blocks us from knowing ourselves is
other people's opinions so many of us
are in constant disconnect with
ourselves because we're always
validating or verifying others opinions
of us so
what do you think we let others ideas
and beliefs define how we feel instead
of being guided by our own values
following others opinions blindly can
quickly get us lost before i decided to
become a monk i was training to be an
investment bank or a working business
when i stopped to look at why i was
chasing this career that i wasn't really
interested in i realized i was following
my community's definition of success and
not my own this isn't me step back and
ask yourself why am i doing this is it
because it's what you truly want or is
it because it's societies or someone
else's opinion of what you should do or
want if you want to know yourself and if
you want to experience meaning and
purpose this is the kind of stuff you
want to fill your life with your values
should come first when you isolate your
values you'll start to see more clearly
what's important to you you'll start to
get a sense of your passion and your
purpose and you'll be able to start to
see and understand what choices will
bring you closer to the life of your
dreams beth canopic
understands
eight years ago she lost her 16 year old
daughter lyanna when suddenly and
inexplicably a virus lyanna contracted
migrated to her heart
it could not be cured
after a tumultuous month in the hospital
beth's vibrant joyful athletic daughter
was gone
it's every parent's worst nightmare and
as you'd imagine it catapulted beth into
what seemed like bottomless grief
and yet last year something incredible
happened beth gathered 14 other mothers
in and around her florida town who had
all lost children for lunch she says
there wasn't a dry eye in the room only
the tears weren't from sadness they were
from joy somehow each one of these
mothers some of whom had lost more than
one child were able to share positive
loving memories of their children along
with the beautiful ways their lives had
changed as a result of their profound
loss of course every one of these women
would rather have had their children
back
but remarkably they were able to take
what had happened and allow something
powerful
to grow from it as one of my good
friends ray dalio says
pain
plus reflection equals progress i always
thought that we wasted time because we
were lazy or we were indecisive and
while some of these things may be true
for you there actually is a deeper
reason why we feel that way one of my
favorite books is called flow i was
recently rereading it on the blinkist
app flow talks about flow state which is
experienced by musicians rappers singers
athletes when they're in the zone when
they're performing at such a high level
they even forget space time and
everything around them and you get to
see art or magic in real life
now there are a lot of amazing lessons
inside flow but one of my favorite ones
is this discussion when you're looking
at skills versus challenges how many of
you have ever felt that you don't have
the best skills in an area and the
challenge feels really high
chances are if you've experienced that
you end up feeling frustrated or stuck
and disappointed in yourself and that's
one of the reasons why you start
overthinking and procrastinating you
don't have the skills you have a
challenge or a goal that's set really
high and now you feel overwhelmed and
overburdened by the height of that
target that you just give up and stop
working sometimes we have the opposite
experience where our skill is really
high but actually we haven't looked at
our challenges we've been doing the same
thing over and over again we've been
repeating the easy win and in that
situation we sometimes feel bored lost
or confused we feel like our life
doesn't have meaning it doesn't have
purpose and there's nothing exciting or
thrilling about the work that we do the
author goes on to say that flow is
achieved when our skill
meets our challenge so when we really
want to experience that flow state being
in the zone feeling that momentum
feeling that energy thriving we have to
make sure that our skill and challenges
match are we feeling frustrated and
stuck because our skills are too low and
our challenges are too high
or are we feeling bored because our
skills are too high and our challenges
are low in either case we want to focus
on either increasing our skills or
increasing our challenge
that helps us focus on the area that we
actually need to have an impact and we
stop wasting time with all the
distractions so now instead of
procrastinating and overthinking we
start focusing on a list of things that
can help us improve our skills you have
books
coaching mentors communities courses all
of these are phenomenal ways to start
learning now if you're someone who needs
to increase your challenge your
challenge can be increased through
networking
i remember when i used to speak or get
invited to speak at colleges and schools
i love that experience i still do it
today whenever i can
but at one point i realized i wanted to
stretch my comfort zone then i started
working with corporate companies because
i really wanted to help organizations
build new models of thinking today i
work with so many fortune 500 companies
and enjoy the experience deeply but i
also wanted to extend my challenge
beyond that i started speaking on stages
i started speaking at my own events what
i found is that you can extend
your challenge by increasing your goals
or targets
or by changing the scale or the depth
sometimes we challenge ourselves by
trying to affect more people do more
things and sometimes we challenge
ourselves by going deeper in the areas
we're already in and finally a new way
of challenging yourself is a new
industry when you think about someone
like michael jordan who went off to play
baseball or you think about steve jobs
who went into movies and pixar and
animation people have challenged
themselves across industries when
they've truly mastered their field so
the question i want you to answer is
this instead of procrastinating and
overthinking do you need to work on your
skills or do you need to work on your
challenges and you'll know where to
start the first thing
is that purpose is like an adult right
finding your purpose is like an adult in
terms of growth passion is like a
teenager but before you become a
teenager what are you you're a child
child is like the interest and before
you're a child you're a baby that's
curiosity
so at the baby stage of passion what you
first need is curiosity that curiosity
turns into an interest that interest
turns into a passion that passion turns
into a purpose for so many of us we get
stuck trying to be like well what's my
passion it's like saying well i should
be a teenager before i'm even a baby
let's first learn to crawl before we
learn to walk or run or fly
so when we start that we ask yourself
what am i curious about what could i
watch documentaries about forever what
could i get excited about learning
forever what is it that i keep getting
up to do even if i fail what is it that
i get motivated to learn about or hear
about or read about or watch about even
when i don't know so much about it what
are you naturally curious about and
drawn towards in your life that is the
birthplace of your passion it doesn't
have to be a passion just yet it just
needs to be a curiosity or an interest
when you're going on a long car trip you
take your car to the mechanic first
right to get things recalibrated
realigned and ready to go that's our
second m how we're going to recalibrate
for our new journey is to adjust our
self-awareness neuroscientist david
eagleman says that as far as our brains
are concerned as adults we are more like
our peers than our childhood selves yet
when we think about who we are we mostly
base our ideas on our younger self so
tune up your self-awareness you're going
to go on a data gathering expedition
among those who know you best simon
sinek the author of start with why has a
great exercise for this when people say
i don't know what i'm good at or i don't
really know what my unique abilities are
that's because it can be hard to get an
accurate picture of yourself from the
inside right there's a saying that you
can't read the label from inside the jar
so you're going to ask people outside
your jar to help you out can you help me
you're going to ask three to five people
who know you well it may be personal
professional friends to describe for you
what makes you special
ask them simon recommends why are you
friends with me
why did you pick me as your partner or
what makes me stand out as an employee
what do you really like about me as your
parent now be aware most people will
answer first with something general
you're smart you're funny you're a good
listener that's not deep enough anything
else
ask for more for example lots of people
are funny why are you friends with me
instead of someone else who's funny or
lots of employees are dedicated can you
give me more detail like a specific
incident or example that really showed
you that tell me more then you'll start
getting the truly helpful data and
information such as
i love the way you use humor to make
other people feel welcome and
comfortable or you have this ability to
take our discussions deeper by bringing
in insights from lots of other fields
that's very nice of you to say you start
to see yourself through others eyes and
get an understanding of what's working
what your strengths are that you can go
deeper on and maximize and what makes
you uniquely you here's an awesome idea
convene a feel-good round table in
person or over zoom with a few good
friends or family members or even do
this with co-workers where you go around
and tell each other some of your
greatest strengths in detail then you're
spreading the love and the joy and the
support as well and it doesn't feel as
awkward as just asking it for yourself
please don't make this awkward for me
okay so what else do we need to start a
journey strong we need some idea of
where we're going right
a map that's our third end you just
learned about all these great things
you've got going for you but no doubt
you also have an area or two or twelve
that's me where you'd like to grow so
we're going to create a map of how to
get there and one way you can do that is
to pick a mentor someone who embodies
that quality or those qualities you're
looking to grow this year one of my
greatest mentors is martin luther king
jr specifically the way he inspired
people for a meaningful course and
connected people to his powerful words
maybe if you want to become better at
relating to others your mentor is oprah
winfrey maybe if you want to be more
strategic and thoughtful when it comes
to business it's your father or mother
that was the case for john mackey the
founder of whole foods his father was
his business mentor for years maybe if
you want to cultivate innovation or
persistence your mentor is someone like
sir james dyson or richard branson next
figure our basic simple ways to connect
with your mentor regularly if it's not
someone you can connect with in real
life you can read their work watch their
videos listen to a podcast read about
their lives tape an inspiring fact about
them or quote from them above your desk
or put it into your wallet remember it's
not that you want to mimic your mentor
you want to be yourself and combine
those strengths you're developing with
those great strengths you already have
in place but if you look at some of the
geography your mentor has traveled it
can help provide you with your own map
for developing those strengths in a 2019
employee survey at pwc 71 of millennials
said their money stress had gone up over
the past years it is stressing
me out and nearly half of all
respondents said that they spent three
hours or more every week thinking about
or trying to sort out their finances and
money woes don't just affect us
individually 44 of young adults said
that the money is the number one
stressor in
relationship
i need to borrow their
and check out these stats according to
erin lowry creator of the broke
millennial blog the average millennial
graduated with 37 000 in student debt
that's in the states and some have much
more that's enough to buy a brand new
car or put a down payment on a house
maybe you're like yeah don't remind me
jay hey i get it lots of us come from
tough places financially and you might
be there now growing up my family
definitely was not what you'd call
wealthy for some of us the hard times
actually helped spur us on to success
here's one of the stories that's really
inspired me it's of a young man who at
14 was evicted with his mother from
their apartment and couldn't afford a
place to live by the time he was 16 he
was arrested multiple times though he
went on to secure a spot to play
american football at a top college in
his junior year he lost his spot and his
nfl career opportunities with it at one
point he found himself with only seven
dollars in his pocket but he kept
working and striving and today dwayne
the rock johnson says that every time he
experiences a big moment of success he
reminds himself of those early struggles
when his back was up against the wall
and the only way to go was forward and
that's why he named his company seven
bucks productions still even if you
don't have aspirations of becoming a
mega movie star financial security is
within reach and the place to start is
to stop wasting money now a little
disclaimer first what i'm going to share
with you is for informational purposes
only it is definitely not intended as
formal legal tax investment financial or
other advice you want to consult a
qualified licensed professional for that
okay so here are those five big areas
where you can stop wasting money and get
yourself on track financially take notes
boys let's start with a super common one
that's really simple financial expert
sus ormond says if you're buying a
coffee every day you may be literally
flushing your chance to be a millionaire
down the drain you know because after
the coffee goes through your body
okay never mind you get it anyway almond
says that if you invested that 100 or
more per month so many of us spend on
coffee in a roth retirement account over
40 years with compound interest you'd
have a million dollars
that's worth making your own coffee
right actually the entire category of
food and drink is a big one not only do
we spend loads of money eating out for
dinner another big money waster people
often overlook is lunch here's a quick
quiz how much do you think the average
person spends on lunch in a year
according to visa is it
a
520
b
1280
and c
2 746
if you guess c you're right the average
person spends 2
746 per year on lunches now check this
out if instead of buying lunch you
invested that money every month in a
basic savings account over 20 years
you'd have i hope you're sitting down
because this is unbelievable you'd have
60
760 dollars and 41 cents i'm gonna sit
down and that's just with basic
compounding interest okay so here's
another big way we waste money buying
new now here's the thing i know for lots
of us i'll be honest myself included how
we look is important you enjoy fashion
but you can continue to have your unique
look and have favorite brands and still
spend less money on clothing here's a
way to do that i have another friend
who's into designer brands but would
never pay designer prices her secret is
to shop at consignment stores and now
that there are lots of these stores
online there are tons of items to choose
from and you can even shop by your
favorite brands the other month i
complimented my friend on a sweater and
she told me she got it for 65
less than the original price and it came
brand new with the tag still attached
plus shopping consignment also benefits
the environment because we're
recirculating clothes instead of just
making more stuff beyond clothing there
are loads of things we tend to buy brand
new that we really don't need to for
example if your iphone breaks you can
actually buy a refurbished one directly
from apple for way less money and they
come with a warranty and don't get me
started on cars here's another quiz when
you drive a new car off the lot it
literally immediately loses a certain
percentage of its value what percentage
is it a
5
b
10
or c 30
the answer is b
according to carfax the second you drive
a new car off the lot it loses at least
10 in value over the first year it loses
about 20 percent of its value that means
if you spend 30
dollars on a brand new car within a year
it's worth only twenty four thousand
dollars and the value just keeps going
down instead of needing everything brand
new look at what you can buy used or
borrow from someone you know and that's
another way we waste money we buy things
immediately we think of it we get all
excited we go online and buy it it's
like when the apple watch first came out
and i went out and bought one i was so
stoked but no offense to the product i
discovered pretty quickly just in time
to give it back that i didn't actually
need it ended up returning it
take it back instead of impulse buying
that's your purchases if you say oh i
need to buy that whatever it may be and
then go to amazon and buy it and then
later in the day i wanted to get some of
that other thing i love and then go on
to amazon or another store to buy that
what happens when you get your card
statement it all adds up and you're like
whoa how did i spend that much money i
don't remember any of that and that's
because fifteen dollars here and ten
dollars there doesn't seem like much of
the time especially when you're using a
credit card or other digital payment
because you don't see the money you
don't feel it you don't actually have
that experience of giving it away or
holding on to it instead when you think
of something you need and i'm putting
need in quotes because it might not be a
real need but a want put it in your cart
and leave it there or write it down on a
list don't buy it right away then at
some specified time like the end of the
week look at your list or your carts and
choose what it is you really need that
will give you a better idea of what
you're actually spending and what you
actually need versus what you want if
you're a musician serve if you're a
coder serve if you're a
orchestra leader serve if you're a
entrepreneur serve like make your life
about service and helping other people
not just to feel good but make that the
reason why you do what you do
don't make that what happens because you
have money make that the reason you do
what you do yeah and if people start
with service then you'll experience love
then you'll experience compassion then
you'll experience gratitude services
gandhi said that you find yourself when
you lose yourself in the service of
others
and and that's the deepest level of
self-actualization so know that you're
the soul and the consciousness not the
body
know that you have a unique genius and
don't settle for any less
and use both of those to serve
other people as the reason for the first
two so i'm sure you've heard the phrase
before success is the best revenge in my
opinion the best revenge is no revenge
at all what why revenge in latin was
often referred to as vindicta or injuria
and today the dictionary definition
shows revenge to being a resentful of
vindictive spirit now i don't know about
you but when i hear about words like
resent vindictive injury what i find is
that you can't fix yourself by breaking
someone else
that's a good point it's so true that
sometimes people cause us the greatest
pain the greatest suffering the greatest
betrayal the greatest lack of trust
miscommunication and almost destroy our
insides but when that happens you have a
choice to move forward or to destroy
yourself further see when you think that
success is the best revenge or you want
to take any revenge in any form at all
it's like holding a hot piece of coal
wanting to throw it at someone else in
the process of picking up that hot piece
of coal we burn our own palm we burn our
own hand even if we get to the point of
chucking it at the person we've already
caused ourselves more pain more strain
and more pressure simply by picking up
the baggage of wanting to get our own
back on someone or wanting to take out
that pain and pressure on another
individual we're now carrying that pain
and pressure ourself and i know it's
easier said than done i know that it's
difficult but if someone has caused you
pain don't allow them to win by doing it
to yourself again at this time remember
the person that broke you is not going
to be the person to fix you your growth
your healing is totally up to you and
that's why the best revenge is no
revenge at all what happens in society
is that we're clouded by the noise the
noise of family expectations the noise
of our parents i grew up in a family
where you could either be a doctor a
lawyer or a failure those were my three
options anything else would just count
me as a failure right i'm standing up
here in front of you all as a failure we
focus so much on life in what we want to
be as opposed to who we want to be we've
always been told that life and jobs and
careers are like boxes and containers
there's only a finite number of options
you can decide right now that i don't
want to be defined by this box i don't
want to be defined by this container i
don't want to feel that if only i live
in this container then i'll be able to
be successful most of us have been to
school most of us may have been to
college or university but most of us
will feel that our education let us down
our education didn't give us the skills
the abilities the mindset that help us
thrive in life
no they
did not and most of all our education
did not prepare us for our real future
real decisions real relationships that's
why so many of us feel lost confused and
bewildered as we get older in life from
20 to 30 to 40 to 50 and look back and
wonder what did we learn and that's
because at school we learn what to think
but not how to think and the ideal
education system has three elements an
ideal education is an education of the
head
the heart
and the hand let me explain what i mean
please
please do the education of the head is
what we already receive academics
knowledge of math knowledge of english
science history geography these subjects
equip us with knowledge ideas thoughts
they educate our head they make us
understand things they improve our
memory when we learn them when we're
tested on them these are all valuable
skills for our future the challenge is
that's currently all we get
i guess that's it
yep the two that are often missed out
are the heart and the hand and education
in the heart is understanding the values
that lead to long-term growth and
long-term success things like empathy
kindness compassion being able to have
emotional intelligence being able to be
aware of yourself and aware of others
around you knowing how to communicate
effectively knowing how to respect
others beliefs and boundaries knowing
how to read in between the lines of
other people's thoughts and emotions you
good this education in the heart would
save us so much time and so much energy
and potentially even so much money
because so much of it is wasted because
we've never been trained to understand
ourselves or understand others do you
understand yes and the final step is an
education in the hand being able to give
being able to teach being able to share
see we remember when we're engaged and
involved we learn more when we're
teaching we learn more when we're giving
when we're experimenting testing trying
things out that's when we accelerate our
growth in learning it's not just when
we're sitting back and waiting to hear
ideas and thoughts when we're taught how
to learn how to teach and how to share
we're able to grow we're able to enhance
we're able to start living far beyond
what we ever imagined because it allows
us to have that opportunity to test
ourselves in reality to test ourselves
with the real person and therefore the
two parts of education that we missed
out on at school are the two we should
invest in for life think about who are
the people that you want to be around
that can help you grow your education of
the heart values that you want to live
by mindsets that you see proving to be
successful in people's lives and think
about opportunities where you can make a
difference in the lives of others gandhi
said that we find ourselves when we lose
ourselves in the service of others when
we use our skills to make a difference
in the life of other people we learn so
much more about those skills we learn so
much more about ourselves and we learn
so much more about the meaning and
fulfillment that comes from making a
difference don't blame school don't
blame your parents don't blame anything
that stopped us from getting a full
education all we have to do is get an
education in the head the heart and the
hand if at any point you feel like
you're not growing you're not moving
forward you're not feeling a positive
boost ask yourself which of these three
am i in need of because it's always
going to be one or two of those three
that you're missing most of us just
throw ourselves into the deep end
and then try swim and figure it out
right monk life actually
begins at like five years old like the
training of monk life is ultimately
training in self-actualization and
self-awareness
it's meant to start when you're five the
problem is we all went to normal schools
that try to put stuff in us rather than
take stuff out of us it's crazy you talk
about this right right right like
you know you were told at school that
you weren't very good and you weren't
going to english and now you have a new
york times best seller right yeah and it
and it's like but no one noticed that
potential inside you no one noticed that
oh lewis was really creative right and
you're not the only person there's so
many people who feel like that so the
modern schooling system didn't
extrapolate your
self-actualization your element and just
try to put maths english science inside
so the point is that you're trying to
get to such a strong foundation that
when you interact in the world you're
going with a sense of strength fuel
energy to make a difference rather than
going into the world and then going oh
my god where am i trying to figure it
out and i find what happens today is
that when you don't we all know this we
i mean self-love has become such a big
thing now that when people don't figure
out yeah it's like a huge trend now
but but my point is that if you don't
start at a place where you have
self-awareness self-actualization
you have figured out what works for you
what your strengths are
how you want to be in an environment
when you walk out there most of us just
pretend to be someone else most of us
get lost most of us get carried away
yeah so my point is
strengthen yourself grow yourself
and then of course interact with the
world i didn't always love reading when
i was growing up i used to love playing
video games i used to love playing
sports i used to like listening to music
and maybe playing around with a few
instruments when i could but i didn't
always love reading
and now i realize it's because i was
always exposed to lots of fiction books
at school we were taught to read fiction
books at college it was all about
fiction books and i realized for me i
really gravitated towards non-fiction
books autobiographies biographies and
self-help books i grew up in a house
where my father was either reading the
bhagavad-gita a book by deepak chopra
jim rohn or tony robbins and so i was
surrounded by these wisdom books and
that's where i found my love for reading
learning and growing one of the things i
fell in love with about non-fiction
books is that you didn't just read them
you could study them you could analyze
them you could extrapolate lessons and
practical action steps that would
transform your life and i really feel
that i've been a student of these books
for over the last 16 to 18 years of my
life and they have made a huge
difference i absolutely love reading
biographies and autobiographies one of
my favorite biographies is by walter
isaacson and it's steve jobs biography
if you haven't read it you have to go
and check it out and again when i typed
it on blinkist i was so happy to see
that they had such an incredible
breakdown of one of my favorite books
the three-piece methodology is fantastic
for biographies and autobiographies
because it helps you learn from people i
think it's so important to learn from
the lives of people that inspire us the
people that we admire the people that
we're intrigued by because guess what at
one point you're going to fail just like
them
and then you can think about what they
did
at one point you're going to have things
happen to you that you didn't plan for
and you'll need to know how to deal with
uncertainty and discomfort just like
they did decision fatigue
now i want you to take a moment to just
jot down what are the decisions you make
every morning before you've got out of
bed
before you get into your commute or
start your work day chances are you
spend a lot of time thinking about what
to wear what to eat that morning you
might even think about what to eat for
lunch what to eat for dinner you might
be wondering around what movie you're
going to watch tonight what episode of
which show you're going to watch when
you get back you may even be thinking
about what meeting do i have what person
do i have to connect with today what do
i even have to do today these are very
common things for a lot of us the
concept of decision fatigue teaches us
that so many of us are making so many
insignificant decisions in the morning
that by the time we start our work day
we're already exhausted from making
decisions we overthink about the smaller
things that should be easy
and now we have no energy for the bigger
things that do require our attention and
our awareness i want you to create a
table of decisions to make the night
before and decisions to make the day off
what that's going to help you do is give
you something to focus on the night
before so that you can be prepared and
well ahead of schedule before the next
day and be really clear about what you
can only do on that day now the night
before you want to be doing that either
at the end of your work day or just
after dinner the reason is because at
the end of your work day you can set
yourself up for success the next day for
those of you that want to leave it till
after dinner the reason why i say after
is because we make better decisions when
we're eaten and when we've nourished so
what we're essentially doing with
decision fatigue is that we're stopping
ourselves from over thinking about the
smaller irrelevant to some degree
insignificant decisions to the more
significant decisions now i'm not saying
that eating food is not important i'm
not saying that what you wear every day
is not important i take pride in what i
eat and what i wear but when i've meal
prepped when i've made a plan a week in
advance when i've made it simple for
myself my brain gets capacity and space
to make these big decisions a really
great example of this is mark zuckerberg
barack obama and others who've been
known to wear the same suits or the same
clothes again and again on repeat now
this is something i personally had
firsthand experience of living as a monk
every day we woke up and we wore robes
we had two sets one to wear one to wash
it simplified that energy in the morning
now today of course i don't wear robes
if not a monk anymore and i have a
wardrobe that i enjoy but inside of it i
have many different things but i have
them in many different colors that way i
still have somewhat of a uniform that
simplifies that or i make a decision the
night before now there is no
relationship in the world where people
don't argue if a couple says they don't
argue it can mean one of two things
either they're just getting to know each
other or they're lying are you calling
me a liar i'm calling you one if you are
one managing conflict is one of the most
important skills in any relationship the
one simple question that improves any
relationship is how will i feel in one
year about this current conflict in my
relationship people feel more forgiving
and interpret their relationship in a
more positive light when looking at it
from a future perspective when couples
and partners argue about finances family
jealousy or attention or whatever it may
be in those situations we use our
current feelings as fuel for a heated
argument
but with this simple shift where we're
envisioning our relationships from the
future we're actually able to mitigate
conflicts and think of things with a
bigger perspective and picture everybody
calm down when we start thinking about
things through the future we use more
long-term thinking we start using our
reasoning strategies our more mature
intelligence rather than our currently
emotion-filled mind how many times have
you said something in the moment that
you regret later how many times have you
made an impulse decision that you later
recognize wasn't the right one a lot
actually when we employ future
perspective thinking we get the ability
to rise above our current emotions and
start thinking from a point of
intelligence when we do this we blame
our partners less we take more
responsibility about what we can change
we're more forgiving and we're even more
able to focus on why the conflict
happened in the first place how many
times have you started an argument let
it continue for days and even forgotten
why it started i can't remember anything
that happened before two weeks ago next
time you're in a conflict an argument or
a debate with your partner ask yourself
this question how will i feel in one
year about this current conflict in my
relationship it will make a difference
and it will surely give you perspective
just around two years ago i had this
idea i wanted to share wisdom at a pace
we wanted entertainment i wanted to
share wisdom in a way that it could
connect resonate and deeply evolve the
lives of people all over the world for
10 years before that i've been working
with individuals groups coaching at
universities companies and all of these
opportunities but i really wanted to
serve and connect with everyone across
the world i wanted to make wisdom
accessible to anyone who had one of
these i have one of those
so i was excited i had the energy the
enthusiasm and i was pitching my idea to
every single company that was online now
remember this is before i ever made a
single video before any of you knew who
i was
who's this guy i applied to not 10 not
20 but 30 online media companies hoping
that one of them would like my series
idea i waited a day i waited two days
away to the week i was rejected by every
single one of those companies before
interview none of them invited me for a
phone interview none of them invited me
for a video interview none of them even
connected with me in any personal way
that's rude
i said to myself it doesn't matter let's
see what else i can do to try and make
my goal a reality
so i tried to network with people who
may be able to give me a chance i got
one answer and one answer only they said
you're getting older now most of the
people who want to break into this
industry around 21 years old just don't
worry about it other people said to me
look you need to go get a media and
journalism degree or a master's and then
we'll take you seriously literally i was
getting rejected from every single
person i spoke to but inside of me i had
this desire i had this calling i had
this mission i had this vision that i
wanted to share everything that i had
learned with people out there i
genuinely tried every single possible
method i could to break into the media
industry to the point that the only
thing that was left that i could try was
to start a social media channel and of
course you know the rest the most
incredible thing is that it reminds me
of a really powerful thought from thomas
edison he once said when you believe
you've exhausted all options remember
this you haven't that thought stayed in
my mind the whole time what i learned
from all of this rejection from all of
this failure from all of these clear
no's was one really important thing and
today i want to give that as a gift to
you me
if you have a dream you have an idea you
have a vision we have to take the
responsibility to prove our worth before
we expect anyone to value our talent
when i started crafting and creating my
own videos teaching myself how to edit
learning how to produce understanding
the mechanics of social media when i
started putting my energy into that
space that's when people started to take
notice that's when people started to
listen that's when things started to
happen
this is nice
it's when i decided to take the
responsibility for sharing what i was
passionate about with the world and not
waiting for someone external to validate
me or give me permission or allow me to
do that that's what made the difference
if you're feeling you've been going
through a lot of rejections
ask yourself this is your deeper passion
and calling making you want to move
further number two have you truly
knocked on every single door and number
three are you working hard on investing
in your expertise and passion so that
you really have something impactful to
offer steve jobs said that you should
never start a company with the goal of
getting rich it should be about starting
a company to make something you believe
in we should dream to make a difference
break down boundaries build beyond
borders and ignite ideas to innovate
incessantly and create for people where
they can never conjure up themselves
henry ford said that if i had asked
people what they wanted they would have
said faster horses and that's the beauty
of going beyond wanting money and going
beyond wanting fame and going beyond
wanting power that you actually craft
something that evolves people's daily
lives that you actually create something
that enhances someone's human experience
people respond to people who want to do
more than just gain for themselves we're
attracted by selflessness we're
attracted by renunciation we're
attracted by the quality of when people
want to give rather than take when they
want to share rather than keep and when
they want to do and serve rather than
just hold
steve jobs said being the richest man in
the cemetery doesn't matter to me what
matters to me is going to sleep feeling
like we've done something wonderful i'm
not telling you to not work at a
corporate i think corporate experience
is great what i'm saying is don't lose
this voice work till 6 pm every day then
go home and work on what you actually
care about use your weekends to not be
on instagram and actually do what you
care about you do that you're investing
in your meaning you can be making enough
money and make the switch
that's what's up for all of you who have
a great degree have a great education
you've got that job lined up use it just
don't become a servant of that job don't
just say oh i'm in prison now i'm just
going to use my weekends to hang out if
you do want to do that that's cool too
if you say to me jay actually whatever
you're saying i don't even want that i
just want to hang out and have a good
time i don't even want meaning or
purpose that's cool with me too but if
you want to be happy and you want to be
fulfilled and you want to have an impact
on the world then use your time wisely i
used to go home after my corporate job
at 8 pm and edit till 1am on my own
every day so do your job get a job if
that's where you need to go with it if
you can't go all in be safe be secure
but then don't waste that time
on not doing that and then complaining
that you don't have what you want one
thing i've been observing is that
achievement or ambition is broken down
into five stages learn experiment
perform struggle thrive right now the
challenge with all of those is is that
we want to thrive all the time we want
to be in thrive zone we want to be
winning those awards getting those views
getting those messages getting those
likes all the time we want to be noticed
and recognized but actually if we took a
step back we realized we need to be
learning we need to be experimenting and
so what happens is that we get confused
by where we are and so our expectation
of what we want is totally blurred and
we start chasing a false reality and
that's why we find that we get
disappointed and confused when we know
we should actually be performing we
actually need to do we need to act
rather than chasing that thriving
feeling all the time so next time you
think things aren't working out next
time you feel you're not on the right
track step back and ask yourself should
i be learning should i be experimenting
should i be thriving should i be
performing or should i be struggling and
that one comes around a lot more than
you can imagine one of my favorite ways
to deal with success is continue trying
to be
the least successful person
in the room that you and i think there's
those statements of like you know that
would be the dumbest person yeah that
would be the smartest person in the room
etc and i think it's the same with
if you become successful
don't just stand at the top of the
mountain don't just stand at the top of
the building
go back down the stairs and and keep
building and keep living as that person
that got you there because you only got
there because you started from the
bottom
right no one starts at the top and so
you started at the bottom and you built
it up and it was that mindset that you
started with that got you there and so
you want to keep rediscovering that
mindset and new parts of it then new
parts of that mindset too
where you're always trying to challenge
yourself and so for me one of the best
ways of dealing with success is keep
expanding the goal posts
right keep widening the goal post keep
making them
harder to reach and challenging yourself
because when you challenge yourself
and you push yourself out of your
comfort zone you're naturally humbled
because you're naturally humbled when
you're walking into space i'm sure you
feel this sometimes like sometimes i
walk into a room and i'm like how did i
even get here yeah right like sitting on
a table like i'm the why should i be
here yeah like and there's part of it
that's impostor syndrome and that can
have its own negativity but part of that
just lets me feel like a beginner again
and i appreciate that feeling and i go
this is amazing because
learning to be grateful
and stop just thinking that oh i earned
all of this and i did it all myself and
i'm self-made you start recognizing
gratitude for all the people that got
you there so for me in success first
thing is be grateful for all your
teachers mentors guides people that got
you there the second thing is always
keep challenging yourself because the
more you're out of your comfort zone the
more naturally you stay humble you don't
stay humble by trying to be humble you
become humbled constantly right by
trying to do stuff that's out of your
league which constantly makes you
prepare
work deepen
all that stuff all of that stuff that
makes you go there again and then the
third thing you do with success is i
think you try and share it with others
you try and use your platforms as an
opportunity to give other people a
platform so that they can come up as
well because you're reminded of what a
beautiful gift you have in the book i
talk about how it's about training your
mind for peace and purpose every day and
that's the peace part that's how you
find peace in difficult times you
recognize it's part of the process but i
always like to offer the service element
too which is the future part the purpose
but it's
i would think about the year 2030
or 2050 whichever year
you you want to meditate on 10 years
time 30 years time
and think about your kids or your
grandkids or young people around your
nieces and nephews if you don't have
kids
people around you they'll be going to
school and they'll be learning about
2020 in their history books
and let's say that one of their teachers
assignments is you have to go back to
your parents or grandparents and ask
them what were they doing in 2020
so imagine how you're sitting at a
dining table in 2030 or 2050 your kids
or your grandkids come up to your mom
dad dad mom dad dad mom mom
no dad no mom i don't know what the
language is going to be there
and you just say to your parents they
say
uh what did you do in 2020
and whatever answer you want to give
them in 10 or 30 years time
just do that today and that will
literally clear your mind because as
long as you can give them an answer in
10 to 30 years time that you're going to
be happy with just say you know what we
just stuck together and we got through
it you know what i i got i became an
activist and i really supported this you
know what we just doubled on our
business to make sure we we didn't let
go of anyone and we made sure all of our
teams were well taken care of whatever
answer you you want to give in 10 20
years time that question will give you
so much clarity and that will be the
thing that pulls you through this time
rather than you feeling like you're
pushing through it it's honesty right
like humility means to be honest it's
like the ability to say
this is what this person deserves credit
for and this is what i deserve credit
for and this is what this person it's
like it's kind of like when you write
the acknowledgements of your book
right you write yeah i mean you and i
and i remember doing that process and
really thinking about like who's helped
this book in different ways and everyone
gets their line in the acknowledgement
who's made a difference now your name
goes on the front cover because you
wrote the book
like you want everyone to receive the
credit to the degree they merit it yes
and so you never want someone to feel
like they didn't receive as much credit
as they deserve and at the same time you
don't want to give someone more credit
than they deserve the point of credit is
to give it where credit's due right and
so for me that's honesty that's humility
arrogance and pride is when you start to
feel like
only you did it on your own and we all
know that's just not true like i can't
say i did it all on my own i i just i
can't anyway i definitely can't say that
and i can't say it was all other people
and so that is the that's where honesty
and humility i think live together yeah
either you're someone who finds it hard
to get motivated and productive and be
effective throughout the day you get
distracted or stuck or lost or maybe
you're someone who's ticking off
everything from your to-do list but are
feeling drained fatigued and
dissatisfied at the end of the day if
either of those are you this is the
video to watch the first piece of advice
i'm going to give you is really simple
plan for a commute now for those of you
that are working from home you may be
wondering this doesn't apply to me jay
well actually it does what i find is
that if you create a 10 to 15 minute
commute in your day and instead of
diving straight into work waking up out
of your bed walking to your kitchen
table you actually take a walk around
the block you're basically tricking your
mind to feel like you're going somewhere
one of the reasons why we're all feeling
so encaged and so enclosed is because we
don't feel like we're changing
environment we don't feel like we're
moving from place to place like we were
before so if that's your case i want to
make sure that you find 10 minutes at
the beginning and the end of the day to
go to work and come back from work and
use that as time to actually dive into a
podcast an audio book or a blink on
blinkist whatever works for you to give
yourself some time to prepare for work
when you're with loved ones when you're
with family when you're with your
friends
make a vow to not use technology if you
need to have i've seen these around
where you have a technology jar and
everyone puts their phone in it at the
start of a dinner and takes it at the
end make a vow that when you're with
your friends when you're with your
family that you will not be on your
phone and leave your phones in the same
place in one area so that no one of you
can just get that sneaky moment i have
to take a look at it when you first
start you may be worried that you're
going to be bored of each other
you might even be worried well how's
this person going to compete with my
phone how they're going to entertain me
i mean my phone has access to every form
of entertainment
sit in that discomfort again
and in that discomfort you want to learn
something new about that person you're
going to become more curious your mind
actually has the opportunity
to start building a different bond
earlier i mentioned that you want to
create no technology times in your home
you also want to create no technology
zones in your home in mine and radhi's
home those spaces are the dining table
and the bedroom those are two areas that
we want to be technology free that we've
designated as important areas of
connection and so the dining table and
the bedroom becomes places and zones in
my home where we don't use technology
harvard did a table which i really
believe is what mindful speaking is all
about
so what is this so it's called the it's
called harvard list of emotions but i i
kind of changed the name to emotional
vocabulary because i think it sounds
better
so an emotional vocabulary if you look
at all of the world's emotional
vocabulary it's very limited we use five
words to describe pretty much everything
good
bad yeah okay
fine
so it's like how's your week going good
how's your day been bad how are you
feeling okay literally like we use such
limited words and that may be okay for
the majority of people but in your
personal relationships it's so important
to expand your emotional vocabulary so
this table that harvard has made which
anyone can find just by typing in
harvard list of emotions on google
what that does is that it shows you that
when you say you're sad
what do you actually be in so it gives
you all this list of emotions that sit
under the word sad are you irritated are
you offended are you disappointed have
you been let down the more you expand
your emotional vocabulary the more you
can diagnose how you feel interesting
and the more you can tell your partner
or your friend this is how i'm feeling
this is how i'm actually feeling
and this is one of the biggest mistakes
with words is that we think our words
mean the same thing
now when you say love you might think
forever
and when i say love i might think for
tonight right
and that is literally how the word
love or care or marriage or
forever gets misused abused and thrown
about because we both mean different
things and our meanings are based on our
backgrounds our beliefs our beliefs
about how we were born and how our
experiences culture experiences
everything yeah it forms our meaning so
i really believe that in a relationship
in our communication with words define
words
when you say yeah we're best friends or
friends what does that mean to you when
we're business partners what does that
mean to you a contract in a financial
legal sense is to define the terms right
but in our emotional sense we also need
to define the terms and we don't do that
emotionally enough and that's why we
feel emotionally like someone broke the
contract
and you have nothing to hold them to
because you never made a contract
you never communicated you never
communicated the meaning of these words
exactly and that's why words are so
powerful but they're only powerful when
we agree on the definition yeah i first
learned about this through dan o'reilly
and his irrational labs where at an
event they encouraged us to ask more
vulnerable deep and bigger questions how
many of you are tired of small talk
how many of you start every meeting in
the same way hey how's it going yeah it
was good yeah you know same old weekend
yeah you know it's it's been a lot all
right let's get to work we literally
have the same conversation on repeat
almost seven times a day in every
meeting and guess what neither you nor
the other person enjoys that
conversation now this point also applies
whether you're working on zoom or
whether you're meeting in person again
with people we're so used to asking
someone how are you and it's kind of a
throwaway question people usually come
back and give us one of these five
answers good
bad okay fine or
we don't learn anything about the other
person we don't get an opportunity to
deepen our relationship and it's almost
like we didn't even care when we asked
the question but what if we ask someone
hey what's a challenge that you've been
working through lately how can i help
you through it or what's something that
you're trying to overcome that you may
need an insight on
this type of question gives the person
an opportunity to really share what's
happening that vulnerability allows you
to build a deeper bond and deeper
connection and now you're actually
engaging with someone in a refreshing
way
now if you're like me and you're still
spending a ton of your time on zoom i
mean i'm recording podcasts and
interviews with some of my favorite
authors we recently had oprah on the
podcast about a new book what happened
to you and when i'm speaking to people
on zoom i found that it's even more
difficult to build rapport or a
connection especially if you've never
met them before in person
one of the ways i've been able to cross
this bridge is by being curious but not
creepy now what i mean by that is about
asking someone about something that's in
their background i think by now everyone
knows their zoom shot and their zoom
location they have a few things in the
background maybe a piece of art and
maybe a picture of their family and this
is such a beautiful conversation starter
especially if you're trying to build a
new relationship recently i was on a
call with a client and i asked him about
a really interesting thing that he had
hung on his wall behind it it was a
paintbrush i was so fascinated that i
had to be curious not creepy and ask him
why he had it there he said my first
ever job when i was around 14 years old
is i used to paint fences
and after painting fences i got to paint
rooms and after painting rooms i got to
start painting homes and now he's an
executive and a director of a large
company and he said that he hangs this
paintbrush on his wall to remind him of
where he started give the person you're
speaking to an opportunity to tell you a
story i promise you'll be memorable and
meaningful and if not hopefully it makes
one of you laugh i think the first thing
we have to do with beliefs is you have
to realize everyone has them it's not
like you don't have beliefs just because
you don't know what they are everyone
has beliefs that they're currently
living with and i think life is about
unlearning the beliefs you have and
questioning the beliefs you have and
then creating new ones so the first
thing i do is learning yeah from the
beginning from the beginning what if
your parents had their answers and the
way and the religion and this should we
be questioning it i think we should
question it because questioning the okay
questions
are
the most powerful invention
in the world because questions either
strengthen or weaken a belief
based on the information so questions
aren't always from a place of doubt and
cynicism and trying to find a weakness
questions are a sincere request to
figure out something like when we're
sitting in these interviews you're not
sitting there trying to like be cynical
or be you want to help yourself and
people who are listening and watching
and so that's a question first of all a
question is not to
catch someone of god a question is not
to put someone down a question is not to
mislead people a question is to uplift
yourself and others and when you ask a
question in that way
the answer can either strengthen a
belief you already have or weaken it or
introduce you to a new one because we've
defined our identity by our belief so
imagine you're on one of these assault
courses and you're on this rope and
you're being told to swing to the next
rope
but in order to catch the next rope you
need to let go of this rope
but you're scared because this rope is
currently your safety so your current
belief is your safety and when you have
to consider holding on to another belief
and to entertain both together you're
scared that if that one doesn't hold i'm
basically going to fall so people are
scared that their belief is currently
their safety net and so even if it's
wrong it still makes them feel safe and
they feel comfortable and we don't want
to feel uncomfortable so we'd rather
hold on to that safety net right so the
only way to do it how do we get
comfortable with questioning our beliefs
but not being like
holding on to nothing well realizing
that you don't have to
change your mind or you don't have to
leave what you think in order to
entertain or be curious about anything
and explore like exploring experimenting
and experiencing
can either strengthen the belief you
have or help you find a new one but you
have to do that middle three ease of
exploring exploring experimenting and
experiencing yeah and the problem is
that we are just theoretically thinking
we're not experiencing the benefit i
want you to start creating a five minute
gap between each and every meeting in
your schedule so if a meeting finishes
at 10 a.m the next one starts at 1005. i
don't want you to schedule any meetings
back to back from this point onwards you
may think five minutes is not a lot of
time but that five minute gap can be
life-changing here's how when you take
out time between each meeting you get
that really important time to decompress
and prepare for the next meeting you're
now not shifting your energy from one
thing to another thing to another thing
straight away and feeling like you're
just stressed in between not even
getting time to comprehend what the next
meeting is about i've got five habits
for you that you can do across five
minutes that are going to keep you
feeling productive effective and focused
on your well-being throughout the day
the first one is water it is so
important that we take a moment to
rehydrate between meetings it's so
important to stay hydrated because we
need to be drinking around two to three
liters a day and when we're doing that
it boosts our brain function it allows
us to feel clearer it's fantastic for
making us feel energized throughout the
day the second thing you're going to do
in your five minute gap is walk around
this could be in your bedroom in your
kitchen wherever you get a moment it's
really really important to get moving so
many of us are feeling so stagnant and
stuck at the moment because we're
sitting at our desks all day long we no
longer have a lunch to get up to or a
meeting on the other side of our offices
to meet someone we're in the same place
this is causing a lot of issues with our
posture the way our body feels the way
our muscles are it's not natural for us
to be locked into a sitting position
throughout the whole day the third is to
watch by watch i mean watch a view
a window look out of a window look into
the sky
take a step out for a moment and get
some fresh air it's so important that we
look out into the distance we've got so
used to just staring at screens and
devices and books and schedules that are
right up in our face that we're not
giving our eyes the opportunity to look
out into the distance now this fourth
one's a little more interesting and you
may need a little bit more time for it
but it's the idea of wonder allow your
mind to wonder allow it to think of a
new idea to be creative to think about
something unrelated this is where
creativity comes from this is where that
feeling comes from that you're
innovating that you're allowing your
mind to connect dots that otherwise you
might seem as disconnected and the fifth
and final thing that you can do in those
five minutes is to wind down and one of
the best ways to wind down
is through your breath
allow yourself a few moments to breathe
in for the same amount of time as you
breathe out a very simple way to do this
is breathe in for a count of one to four
and breathe out for a count of one to
four how many of you ever felt that your
mind is ahead of your body your mind is
racing around but your body feels
sluggish and tired if you want to bring
your body and mind back into sync back
into alignment you want to breathe in
and breathe out for the same amount of
time doing this breathing practice
allows you to walk in with a clear mind
with a relaxed body and reduces your
anxiety throughout the day
okay how much are you gonna put on me
is there a need like when would you put
this on in the day i like cleansing my
face at night
is it cold it's very hard cleansing is
actually meant to be a very um
mindful activity okay go on make it
mindful just be quiet would you uh will
you do this for me every day when you're
at home absolutely not are you doing
just for the video just for the video
there you go
lovely all right you look brand new
okay so what do we do now so now we have
to get a
it's so hose
i have no idea what's going on you look
great that kind of feels like it's off
it's actually up
yeah it's off enough
yeah but now you're how is that now you
dry it ready
how does it feel
it feels really nice does it feel really
smell nice i feel refreshed you can't be
logical and creative at the same time
your brain and mind is using different
faculties and different abilities to do
different types of tasks imagine you're
in meetings all day about numbers and
data and analytics and all of a sudden
you're asked to do something creative
maybe write a speech or give a
presentation it can be really really
difficult to switch from one side of
your brain to the other side in a matter
of seconds with very little organizing
and planning we're literally going like
a pendulum swinging from one task to
another which is requiring different
parts of our brain and the abilities
that we have the way i solve this is
that i start every day by first writing
down my to-do list i look at all the
activities that i have to do now in the
examples i give in this video i've
simplified my task to make it easier but
know that i do this with a lot more
detail you want to draw a line down the
middle of the page on one side of it
write logical and on the other side of
it write creative
you now want to plot and mark where
these tasks on your to-do list fit
either in the logical category or in the
creative category the question you're
asking yourself is is this task largely
structured
focused does it have certain boundaries
is it quite a logical step-by-step
process
or is this creative is it more of a
brainstorm is it somewhere where you
need to feel free and expressive after
you've divided these tasks you now want
to write down the time estimate that
that specific task is going to take what
ends up happening is you start to plot
your week by saying monday is going to
be creative tuesdays are logical
wednesdays are logical thursdays are
creative and fridays are creative
or you may also divide your day up into
logical mornings and creative afternoons
or creative mornings and logical
afternoons this division this time
blocking allows you to get really
immersed into the activity really focus
and be more productive and effective but
here's a way that you can actually get
more out of the same time i learned this
from my good friend ariana huffington
who speaks about habit stacking now we
all have habits in our life that we do
every single day without even thinking
about it we're driving around town we're
cooking every single day we may be on a
walk
these are great times to immerse in
those activities for sure when you're
driving to be fully present if you're
going on a hike to be really there
within nature and if you're cooking to
be really present with the scents the
sounds and and all of the different
colors that may be there
but
if you're someone who can do some of
those things pretty comfortably you can
also add a stack of a habit so for
example you may be someone who listens
to an audio book while driving you may
be someone that listens to a podcast
while cooking or while you're on a hike
or walking the dog it's okay to have it
stack in those scenarios to get more out
of the same amount of time i wrote about
this in my book
it's called location has energy time has
memory when you do something in the same
place every day at the same time every
day that space builds an energy and that
time builds a memory what does that mean
when you've done something in one place
like meditated in the same place for a
considerable amount of time that space
takes on a meditative energy and
frequency it becomes easier to do that
activity in that place and similarly
when you do something at the same time
every day that time has a memory your
body your mind remember that and
therefore it becomes easier to do
divide your home even in corners i
remember when my wife and i lived in a
500 square foot apartment and literally
every corner of that room was divided
into a meditation corner a social corner
a work corner and an eating corner even
that differentiation allowed you to keep
the energy of that space sacred and
appropriate for what you want to do the
challenge today is we eat where we're
meant to sleep we sleep where we're
meant to work and we work when we're
meant to eat so we've confused the
energy of our environment that's why
we're sitting in bed and can't sleep
because we do so many different
activities there
remove that energy from the bedroom
place it where it needs to be and allow
yourself to see how you use your time
more effectively in that place the
incredible thing about gratitude is that
when you're present in gratitude you
can't be anywhere else
that means that if you're having a
thankful thought you can't have a worry
thought if you're having a grateful
thought you can't have an anxious
thought what an incredible creation
gratitude and thankfulness has to be
practiced in a particular way
it has to be first of all expressed
keeping a gratitude journal is wonderful
writing down what you're grateful for is
beautiful but it's only when you express
it that it starts to have the impact
that i'm speaking about
the second way it has to be practiced is
it has to be specific it has to be
specific to the person it has to be
something specific that happened
recently that's current or even if it
happened in the past
and the third is it has to be
personalized it has to be something that
you'd only say to them it's not
something that you could send to 20
people and they could all feel it was
about them
let me give you an example two people
come to your home for a party they both
text you the day after the party the
first person texts you they'd say jay
thanks so much the second person texts
me and they said jay we had an amazing
time we loved meeting all your friends
we loved meeting your family it was such
a great time and the food was out of
this world thank you so much obviously
taradi and the games that we played were
just so much fun it was the highlight of
my year
which message is going to make you feel
more loved and cared for
obviously it's the second because it's
not only expressed but it's specific and
it's personalized now the amazing thing
about gratitude given in that way is
that not only is the receiver happy but
the giver is so much happier as well the
bond that you create when you share that
type of thankfulness will start to
reduce anxiety in your life because it
boosts your immune system it boosts your
mood and it boosts your relationships
social scientist tim casa studies values
and goals including two types of
motivation extrinsic such as for money
image or status and intrinsic such as
for personal growth close relationships
and making the world a better place he
and his colleagues have consistently
found that people who place a high value
on extrinsic versus intrinsic goals are
less happy and report lower levels of
satisfaction with life along with higher
levels of anxiety and depression and
external rewards can even decrease the
internal motivation you already have
researchers took a group of kids at a
nursery school who had a natural love of
drawing in one group the children were
just left to draw in another they were
told they could earn a good player award
which included a ribbon and a
certificate if they drew a picture two
weeks later the same kids were offered
the opportunity to draw pictures those
who were allowed to just draw showed the
same high level of interest in drawing
the second time around but those who
were told they could earn a reward by
drawing a picture the first time around
were half as likely to want to draw
another picture
what's in it for me the external reward
actually made them less motivated to
draw when we do things out of intrinsic
motivation we're more likely to find
meaning and purpose in our lives and our
work for katrina lake it was her love of
data along with wanting to answer the
question
what could the future of retail look
like here are three ways to connect with
your intrinsic motivation first live for
who you want to become create a vision
of who you want to be in five years in
that vision of yourself list out five
ways you're feeling about your life and
your work and your relationships are you
excited joyful satisfied fulfilled
driven confident be as specific as
possible now for the next week every
time you make a choice ask yourself if
that choice will bring you closer to or
take you further away from that vision
of yourself in five years do you want to
play a video game or read a book do you
want to watch a movie or have a
conversation do you want to take a class
or waste time scrolling on social media
hey there's nothing wrong with any of
the things i said i love them all but we
need the right ratio we need to make
sure that more of our steps are leading
us towards who we want to be then away
it's simple math tip number two is
discover where you can connect something
you're already doing or have a natural
strength or inclination for to something
you're passionate about that connection
point your passion doesn't have to pay
you but if your current job can pay your
passion
that might just be as good and a good
start check this out when computer
science professor louis von on set out
to create dulingo he had one motivation
to make learning free as a kid growing
up in poverty he saw so many kids who
didn't have access to quality education
so he and a partner created dulingo a
language learning app that's now used by
more than 14 million people worldwide
and while the company has become
tremendously profitable ahn's motivation
was never about making money it was
about giving back that's major intrinsic
motivation connecting your passion with
a larger purpose one of my greatest
loves and one of the things that
motivates me is learning and that's the
third tip learning to love learning and
no matter what you do in life you cannot
fail if you look at every situation and
ask yourself what can i learn here
you're going to experience two things
you get to feel curiosity or and wonder
three things that research shows
contribute to feeling satisfaction and
meaning in your life and second if
you're always focused on learning you
will never be disappointed because even
when something doesn't go the way you'd
hoped or planned you can learn from it
as katrina lake says i think a lot of
people find themselves unhappy in their
jobs because it's not their dream but i
think at the end of the day if you're
learning and if you're working with
great people that's going to be a
rewarding experience and that's how you
too
can have a rewarding fulfilling
purposeful life and career mindset have
you ever had that vacation that you've
been getting ready for that you've been
so psyched about and by the time you're
ready packing getting ready to leave
what's happening
stress right you're running around like
what do i pack did we put out the no for
the dog sitter where's our uber
all right here i know my wife and i can
have our moments when we're both trying
to tie things up and get ready for some
time off and it's ridiculous right that
that's how we're starting out as we set
out on our journey this new year
let's spend some time and energy
deliberately setting our mindset we're
going to do it with gratitude and here's
how writer marcel proust once said let
us be grateful for the people who make
us happy they are the charming gardeners
who make our souls blossom kelly
mcgonagall is a professor and researcher
at stanford university and her work
centers on this idea that stress is
neither good nor bad it's our reaction
to it that matters she says that one of
the most effective positive ways we can
deal with stress is to practice
gratitude but not just any kind of
gratitude specifically she says that
it's the gratitude that focuses on
others and their impact on our lives
that's most effective dr mcgonagall says
that stress is designed to motivate us
to get us to do something in the case of
the stress of loneliness for example
it's designed to move us to connect and
when we can feel gratitude for things
others have done for us it helps us feel
more hopeful more willing to seek help
and support and to offer help and
support to others sounds like an amazing
mindset to start out with right yeah it
does
so every day for one week each morning
when you get up spend three to five
minutes diving deep into one beautiful
or meaningful thing someone has done for
you in your life be specific you're
grateful to your mom for helping you
with your homework or you're grateful
for your best friend in fifth grade for
that time he stood up to someone who is
bullying you and of course it can be
something in recent memory too be sure
to remember the sights sounds and smells
and what was said so you can really
reinforce that memory in your body and
in your brain and it's that you can
climb up a ladder but is it against the
right wall are you climbing up a wall
that you actually want to climb up if
you climb up the left-hand side of the
wall but that wasn't the place you
wanted to be at at the top there's no
point of being at the top
and one of the reasons why we
procrastinate and overthink
is because what we're chasing isn't
meaningful enough it's not purposeful
enough it's not fulfilling enough we
don't realize that we're just trying to
get up the wrong wall and we never take
the first step because we don't actually
care
put your ladder
against a wall that you care about
climbing
i know that when i deeply care about the
pain or suffering of another that i want
to help support or serve
that gets me out of bed more than any
other procrastination technique or hack
in the entire world inspiration helps us
deal with anxiety because when we're
feeling inspired when we're feeling
motivated we're able to use that emotion
to help navigate the anxious emotions
we're having the way i like to get
inspired is by listening to audiobooks
it's also by listening to incredible
speeches recently i had the fortune of
interviewing matthew mcconaughey on my
podcast on purpose and i said to him
that at one point in my life i used to
listen to his oscars acceptance speech
from around 2015 every single day
it's only five minutes i would listen to
in the morning and it would give me this
boost of inspiration instead of starting
my mornings with looking at my phone and
opening my mind up to news notifications
negativity and noise i was starting my
day with an inspirational word maybe an
inspirational paragraph from a book you
love or an inspirational quote your
whole podcast is about on purpose
what's the difference between
discovering your purpose finding your
purpose living it and living a
purposeful life
i think that
living your purpose is where it's so
much about
you and your journey
and living a purposeful life
is when you're now letting that
overflow into everyone else's life
so it's like you want to find your
purpose and you want to feel satisfied
that in that but a purposeful life
is where you are igniting other people's
purposes and it's overflowing yeah with
that love and that compassion and
gratitude and that's hard because it
takes time and you can't expect people
to do that while they're still filling
up too
and and i think sometimes we you know
everyone will always look like they're
finished and they're done and they made
it
you know it's like
no one's ever made it and you speak to
some of the most successful people in
the world and even they don't feel
they've made it and so
we are always doing both at the same
time you're always filling up your
purpose and you're always trying to be
purposeful at the same time but you're
not ever going to be fully in purpose
and you're never fully going to be
purposeful it's all a symbiotic
relationship that has to happen in
parallel yeah does that make sense to
your question makes sense to me what i
want you to do is start scheduling time
with yourself in your diary in your
calendar you would never cancel an
important meeting with someone else but
we don't even schedule one with
ourselves if you start by having that
time as your meditation time or you're
not on your phone you're not watching tv
you're not listening to a message or
responding to an email you just sit with
yourself and check in with yourself
and you ask yourself
how am i doing today how do i feel what
do i need to do better
just checking in with yourself is the
beginning of your meditation practice
words that we should use
more of in our life
are words that
give us
the right feeling we want to feel so
i'll give an example
instead of saying now i work super hard
i do get tired
and i do get exhausted sometimes
i'm very aware of it and i'm cautious of
it
and i realized that for a long time i
just kept repeating i'm tired i'm
exhausted i'm tired i'm exhausted and
i'd say to my wife i'd say to my team
overwhelmed
yeah and i still do it sometimes so it's
not that i'm perfect but you're making
me aware of it and i say that i started
to realize that okay it didn't make me
feel better by saying it and actually
what i was trying to do was get
validation from someone else to be like
i know how hard you work and you're
amazing and blah blah blah
and so you know you're really doing it
for a reaction and then i started to
realize well i am tired but why don't i
just say
i'm gonna make some time to nap today
uh i need to i need to find some time
today to rest
i need to make sure that i uh you know
get some time to myself today like when
you flip it not by just saying oh i feel
amazing because i don't feel amazing
again you don't lie to yourself but
you're trying to create words that help
you actually get what you need so me
saying i'm tired
really what i need to be saying is i
need to get some more rest today i
better sleep early and then you go all
right you know to rather rather you know
what i think i'm going to sleep early
tonight
that's that's perfect because now i'll
sleep early and i'll get the rest and i
won't be tired
right i'm so tired it just creates this
negative pattern of complaining and
whining we know that we have around 60
to 80 000 thoughts per day
the most incredible thing is these
thoughts are cycling they're not only
repetitive but they're also negative i
realize that knowing which of the most
repetitive and negative thoughts allows
you to spot their trigger do you
experience this when you're on social
media do you experience this when you're
watching a particular show or you're
around certain people what we want to do
is find that trigger trace that trigger
back to its root and reduce that
activity in our life often what we think
is causing us anxiety is different from
the root of where it started it was
wayne dyer who said when we change the
way we look at things the things we look
at change let's look at our thoughts
differently stop thinking that you are
your thoughts and that your thoughts are
all you are recognizing that we're so
much more beyond our thoughts allows us
to disconnect and distance from them and
then upgrade them towards healthier
thoughts priority how many of you have
tried to change everything all at the
same time you say to yourself i want to
work on my health i'm going to improve
my career i'm going to get promoted this
year and we're going to go on date night
every night you start getting fixated on
improving every area of your life it
comes from this desire to be better and
do more but the truth is
you have to choose that one big priority
it has to be not only at the top of the
list in the beginning it has to be the
list there is only one thing you can
improve at a time and you need to choose
wisely it's so easy to get caught up and
think i want to improve my career i also
want to learn more i also want to work
on my relationship i also want to work
on my health we have to stop that and
say this
is my big priority for the next 30 days
make your first step a small step you
may want to be up here but you need to
start down here you need to take the
first step the reason why most people
never get started is that their goal is
so big that they think they have to
achieve that on day one they think that
if they don't get there
they can't start here and this is the
most debilitating frustrating feeling
and that's why we have to simplify and
create that first small step
reading is one of my favorite things to
do but sometimes my stack of books that
i want to read is bigger than the amount
of time i have and at the same time i'm
trying to figure out which one am i
going to get the most value from and
often i'll overthink and procrastinate
so so many friends will come to me and
say my partner doesn't spend enough time
or i don't have enough time
and what they're really saying is from a
partner point of view is
i really want energy
intimacy and presence and attention it's
attention you're not asking for time
you're asking for attention and i've had
friends who have gone on weekends away
with their partners and they'll come
back and their partner on monday morning
will say i wish we had more time
together and the partners thinking well
but we just spent the whole weekend
together but they're like no because you
were doing your work and by the beach
and you were reading your book and i was
trying to take care of the kids and you
realize it was never time it was a
tension it was intimacy it was presence
and so if we don't define those words
right words are all about definitions if
you don't define them people will break
that contract and their emotional
contract and you have nothing to hold
them to you want to make sure that in
any habit change there is some reward
and a reward is making sure you
recognize what amazing growth you're
making that you're taking a moment to
see look how far i've come because our
mind again tricks us and always goes
look how far you have to go it's really
important that you remind yourself of
how far you've come how much you've
grown the difference you've made with
this principle it was actually a study
by amy versniewski and her team at the
yale school of management they wanted to
go and research what they believed was
the most difficult job in the world
hospital cleaners and this was
pre-pandemic
these were people who had to clean up
the hospital rooms hospital beds
hospital toilets after people ate and
even often people passed away you can
only imagine what a challenging and
difficult job it is they went and
interviewed some hospital cleaners some
of them described themselves as cleaners
they described the activities that i
just stated and described themselves as
doing that kind of labor now another
group of hospital cleaners they
described themselves as healers
servers carers transformers they did the
same exact work as the other cleaners in
the same hospitals
but they saw themselves as directly
connected towards the healing journey of
the patient and the patient's family
they saw their work that if they could
make an environment clean that that
would be better for the patient and the
patient's family they saw it as a way of
serving
someone's journey towards healing this
mindset which amy brzeznuski and her
team called job crafting
is where you look at your work
differently
so many of us get caught up on that
excel spreadsheet we get caught up on
that powerpoint presentation we get
caught up on doing the actual task
but we forget to look up
look beyond our laptops look beyond our
screens zoom out
and think about the impact that our work
actually has on others
your work may be allowing you to put
food on the table and take care of your
family it may be helping your children
go to a specific school it may be
helping them have certain opportunities
when you look up from the task and you
focus on what your work truly allows you
and the people you love to do
you start looking far beyond
than just that activity think about that
today zoom out and that reduces the
anxiety it reduces the stress that is
attached to the day-to-day task and
allows you to look at it from a
bird's-eye view i think actions that we
should be adding more of in our life are
actions that
create positive habits i think it has to
be habits orientated it has to be stuff
that we can repeat
and and
in think like a monk i talk about the
four key habits in your day which are
thankfulness
inspiration
meditation and exercise which is the
acronym of time
so make more time in your day for
thankfulness inspiration meditation and
exercise those are four actions that i
think if everyone wants to take in their
day
this is what happens when you're
thankful
you boost your immunity you boost your
self-confidence you boost your mood yeah
because you go oh people love me that
means i matter people care about me that
means i have something to care about so
it boosts your mood and then when you
tell people that you're thankful you now
boost connection and relationship and
when you thank someone you now boost the
feeling of i have people in my life that
care about me and i care about them
so much comes out of that one action
inspiration or insight listening to a
podcast reading a book reading a quote
when you do that again you feel excited
you feel enthused you feel like you're
learning you feel like your mind
actually works and that they can go
somewhere so that's a great action
meditation of course we've talked about
at length in the beginning and exercise
people just don't understand that we
could solve so many of our
challenges simply by sleep and exercise
and diet like those three things change
your life could change your life and and
we have to just get focused on one at a
time
and so what in actions i i talk about
this thing in principle is we want
things to be small steps but big
priorities so if you want to change an
action in your life it needs to be a big
priority and then you need to break it
down into small steps what we try and do
is we try and change everything at the
same time all of us don't have a lot of
time and so one of the reasons we
procrastinate is because we say well i
don't have enough time to figure that
out so i'm just going to put it off i'll
do it next week i'll do it tomorrow i'll
think about it later because we don't
think we have the right amount of time
here's what i've realized and here's a
hack that has helped me break through
that idea i've realized that when i'm
present and focused that's more powerful
than any amount of time when i'm alert
when i'm ready even if i'm there for 15
or 20 minutes i can actually make more
progress than if i had an hour and i
didn't bring my best energy
ask yourself consistently how can you
bring your presence to the task not your
time don't let time be the limiting
factor when i'm having a productive
effective day that doesn't mean i don't
get distracted i get distracted plenty
of times i have tons of notifications
social media big announcements things
that are happening throughout the day
plus a team across the world in
different time zones to manage so when i
get distracted i've created a really
healthy
relationship with distraction i feel
like sometimes our relationship with
distraction is quite negative we see it
as a bad thing we judge ourselves for
feeling distracted we start saying oh i
wish i was more focused or i wish i was
more affected
so i literally got one of these
distraction timers as i call it and i
turn it over as soon as i get distracted
i let the sand run out and as soon as it
runs out i have to get back to my task
this gives me the space and the time to
allow for little distractions and now i
figured out a way to allow myself five
minutes of distraction time every hour
so every hour i allow myself to browse
on my phone for two to five minutes and
that way i know that that time is going
to happen that time is going to come and
that allows me to delay it to put it off
and to postpone my own distractions when
i was around 16 maybe 15 i we used to
celebrate christmas every year and
christmas is probably my favorite time
of year we were talking about
i love uh listening to christmas songs
and i love christmas decoration and for
me christmas is presents it's presents
and and so i grew up in a culture where
we celebrated christmas but christmas
was presents and a family dinner
and because i went to my school in
england we'd celebrate all the religious
holidays so we knew about all the uh
main stories behind every major world
religion and so i remember celebrating
christmas at home but thinking i don't
know that much about jesus and should i
not be connecting with jesus because
that's why we even have this day and so
i started going to church in my local
area just out of curiosity i wasn't
trying to be a christian or trying to be
a hindu or trying to be anything i was
just interested and curious
to be like what is it about christ that
created a day that has lasted thousands
of years that people all over the world
celebrate there must be something here
and so i feel like we get so scared
because we want clear designations we
want like a clear title of i am this or
i am that and that gives us a sense of
safety and security but really answers
come into curiosity not in the security
yeah right what does that identity do to
us in a good way or in a negative way in
a good way it creates a and this isn't
just about religious identity it's any
identity
or whatever yeah it's not about holding
on to this identity of yourself yeah so
in the good sense it surrounds you with
more people like that so if i'm a
podcaster i hang out with more
podcasters we learn more about
podcasting and that's a great thing
because we all become better podcasters
the mistake is i go oh i can only be a
podcaster but i can't write a book i
can't make a video i can't do that now
and that's the mistake that it makes so
it should be evolving these
titles that we give ourselves these
communities should help us evolve not
devolve yeah and and not stop us from
expanding and growing okay and and so
you want to be around people that are
always curious and insightful journaling
can often be seen as a habit that wastes
time you're sitting there writing when
you could be doing something but i find
setting your intention and setting your
desire for the day
is a much more powerful and practical
way to now walk into your day and feel
like you know why you're there
to feel a sense of purpose and so for me
setting an intention before a big
meeting before a difficult phone call
before an awkward conversation reminds
me of who i want to be
in that interaction
and that remembrance that confidence and
clarity around who i want to be allows
me to navigate those seemingly difficult
awkward moments that naturally arise
throughout the day so this is a time
that i take and as you can see from my
notes none of these are beautiful none
of these are perfect none of these are
fully aligned they are scattered
spontaneous sometimes random thoughts
and i allow myself to doodle squiggle
whatever it takes because that allows me
to feel that it's free-flowing stop
trying to make it perfect stop trying to
make it look amazing just make it the
way it allows you to feel like you have
a window into your mind
and so when i look at these notes i
sometimes think i'm just allowing myself
to express what's on my mind right now
turn off your notifications and turn on
chill relaxing work music
i've done this for such a long time
where i have a playlist that i listen to
that allows me to just get into the zone
what i find music does especially
instrumental music that's what i focus
on i try to stay away from popular music
that i may listen to in the car or while
i'm in the gym what that does is it
gives the mind enough distraction enough
rhythm enough pattern enough momentum so
that you can actually focus your mind on
the activity at hand now some of you may
prefer silence or working to chatter and
that's fine too you can even put that
type of music on but for me instrumental
beats and rhythms are a fantastic way of
getting into the zone turning off your
notifications is just a no-brainer if
you're really trying to do some deep
work thoughts are meant to be spotted
stop and reflect and then swap and what
i mean by that is
if you've got a thought that's repeating
like you said and is negative i'm
guessing you don't want that thought
around for too long
so you want to spot when does that
thought arrive
does it arise when i'm with certain
people does it arise when i'm on a
particular social media platform does it
arise when i go to a particular place
where is that what is the seed of that
thought right so once i had identified
that i now need to stop spend some time
in stillness and go is this thought
benefiting me
is this thought useful to me is this
thought actually leading me to who i
want to become and if it's not i need to
swap it with a thought so one of my
favorite ways of let's take an example
of like
i feel less than i feel
uh like i'm not achieving anything i'm
not good i'm no good i'm not good enough
so you spot that and you go i always
feel that when i'm going through this
particular instagram profile because i'm
looking at someone who i think is better
than me okay what do i swap that with
you don't swap that with your beautiful
you're amazing you're incredible because
you may not believe that yet yeah but
you stop it
you swap it with i feel confident when
i feel attractive when i feel happy and
joyful when and you figure out what is
that thing that i need to be and do the
best place to talk about that though
with thoughts is the movie inception
so you look at how a thor is planted
into someone's mind
and how in that movie leonardo dicaprio
in his wife's mind plants a thought
that this is not real and that thought
grows into a belief belief that is so
strong it's crazy right and it's like
that is literally what a thought can do
and you see that in the joker movie
so i i did a whole episode last year
which is all about like mental health
and the joker and you look at the joker
stories he's trying to bring joy to
others but everyone treats him badly and
so the thought sets in if i'm not worthy
i'm not valuable my father doesn't want
me
no one thinks i'm funny everyone
makes fun of me even when i go on tv
everyone's laughing at me
that idea becomes his reality now i get
that that's a fiction movie but the
point is still that we see even in
today's world
that thoughts have the ability to become
i i forget the word that leonardo
dicaprio uses the movie but that thought
yeah cancer or sometimes yeah it's like
a cancer in the mind right it like
really just expands and so i think we
have to be so good at spotting stopping
and swapping thoughts
now it all gets real how much is fast
and how much where am i where are my
faucets
where am i attached to i feel like
that's the only thing that's attaching
us to the zip line
just that one hook
don't think about it
oh my god it all gets real now
you're literally only hooked to one
thing i don't know where am i meant to
uh how far should i be am i doing this
right okay no there's two hooks that's
good what do you think i think you
should have gone first because you're
looking at it
i know i know
i feel like i need the toilet
[Music]
yeah
okay
cool
yes
when are you going to let me off
i'm not sure i want to do this actually
are you sure do you want to want to do
it i don't know bob if you don't want to
do it i don't want you to do it is it no
it's fine no if you don't feel
comfortable but i'm fine are you sure
i didn't know i'm fine
buddy you're all the way up
so you're singing
are you just gonna push me how is this
working just meditate right are you sure
i'm fasting properly
ready keep your legs straight and hold
your harness yeah okay
once you're past this building you can
open your arms i don't want to i'm not
opening myself this view is beautiful
spectacular i'm okay
oh no am i going
when do we go okay you're done give us a
countdown
give me
[Music]
[Music]
who's catching me the other end
okay
yeah but i'm not picking my eyes
[Applause]
i'm turning
that was amazing
[Music]
you made it really i did but i had my
eyes closed 99 of the time
you're not gonna lie
you did it though i did it you did it
the initial bit was scary but this is
always the initial of it
i started turning sideways
[Music]
i'm good man i'm good it was amazing it
was a lot of fun
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for some
incredible motivation from the one and
only tony robbins check the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there great ideas are never going to
interrupt you they have to be pursued
and you if you don't pursue them you're
going to get what everybody else has
which is all this fear all this
uncertainty all this stuff it won't work
because everybody's